welcome to mainframe modernization
accelerating legacy transformation with
google cloud
hi i'm travis webb enterprise solutions
architect at google
thanks for joining me at google cloud
next on air
i work with our customers to help them
solve their biggest
most complex it problems and today
i'm going to discuss mainframe
modernization
a new solution offering from google
this is an introductory talk so we're
going to start out with an
overview of the mainframe ecosystem i'll
then discuss
mainframe's place in our world today and
some common ways that our customers have
tried
often with bad results to migrate off
the mainframe
next i'll introduce google's offering
for mainframe modernization
and finally we'll walk through one
customer's journey
as they migrated thousands of as400 and
mainframe cobalt programs
to run natively in google cloud
let's talk about the mainframe ecosystem
first let me give you a quick overview
of the mainframe market today
the mainframe market is large it
includes the cost of the machines
themselves
but also the fees paid for the usage of
those machines
and licenses for mainframe specific
software
the vast majority of large companies use
mainframes for to run
critical business workloads and many of
those applications
have been built over the course of
decades
mainframe usage extends beyond the very
largest companies
and there are many thousands of
mainframe systems still in use
and each of these systems represents an
opportunity for google
and the customer to come together to
partner on a strategic transformation of
their business
commodity workloads are moving to the
cloud at a rapid pace
mainframe workloads have lagged behind
let's talk about some of the reasons for
this
it's important to remember that for the
most of the history of computing
the idea of running important business
processes
on a personal computer would have you
laughed out of the room
the pc was a toy it was only
in this current millennium that doing
important things on
individual pcs or servers was taken
seriously
so how is the mainframe so
resistant to effective competition
first the ibm mainframe has an unbroken
chain of backward compatibility
going back to the 1960s this
durability has allowed the mainframe to
amass a large installed base of
customers
and a reliable revenue stream for
mainframe vendors
and while the physical systems from the
1960s are no longer in use today
many of the early programs written
decades ago
survive to this day
second our it leaders have a tendency to
closely scrutinize the
entrance costs when evaluating a
technology purchasing decision
while much less attention is paid to the
exit costs
leaving the mainframe platform was
expensive and difficult
and for many businesses the cost of
migrating
still isn't economically viable
a proprietary ecosystem adds to the high
exit costs because many mainframe
applications rely on proprietary
technologies
that are not available outside the
mainframe ecosystem
this combination of factors leaves
current mainframe customers
with few viable alternatives
if the mainframe vendor has a large
installed base of customers who can't
leave
why should they invest in innovation
while much improvement occurred
throughout the 20th century
the relative advantages of the mainframe
over other platforms
have eroded over time and today
mainframe customers now find themselves
at a technological and
cost disadvantage compared to their
peers
you no longer need a mainframe to run
intensive processing tasks
but if you already have one you're stuck
paying for it anyway
the interesting thing here is that these
disadvantages are
widely recognized and understood but
mainframe customers had
few viable options available to assist
in migrating their mainframe workloads
to the cloud
with no new customers or developers
entering the ecosystem
mainframe vendors de-emphasized
investment
in innovation
of course around y2k companies started
figuring out
how to use commodity servers to run
business workloads
instead of mainframes google of course
was at the forefront of this movement
and has pioneered many
key data center infrastructure
innovations
we serve customers all over the world
with technology that we've built into
google cloud
and has at a scale that simply would
never have been possible
with mainframes
meanwhile public cloud is democratizing
i.t innovations at an incredible pace
and its explosive growth comes from
companies looking to leverage
modern technologies that their legacy
vendors
aren't providing
it's no secret to anyone that legacy it
is expensive
and mainframe often tops the list but
lots of things are expensive and high
operating costs might be tolerable
if you've also got innovation and
agility in return
but with mainframe you really end up
with the opposite
a static ecosystem that gets more and
more expensive
and makes it harder and harder to
innovate
customer expectations are increasing the
pace of innovation is increasing
yet many mainframe customers see a
chronic
shortage of qualified staff who
understands these technologies
putting at risk decades of investment in
the platform
again these issues are widely recognized
widely understood most acutely by
mainframe customers themselves
and many are saying we want out
companies have tried many different
approaches over the years to migrate off
the mainframe platform
and often never quite achieve escape
velocity
and they end up getting pulled back in
there are three main ways customers
attempt to modernize these legacy
systems on their own
you can undertake a large manual rewrite
of all your mainframe software
into the cool new language of the week
you can use an
emulator to run your entire mainframe
environment
on normal computers or you can modernize
in place
keeping the mainframe but updating the
software
we're going over these approaches
because they are all
anti-patterns and we want to help
customers avoid these pitfalls in the
future
i've talked to customers in the middle
of a manual rewrite who have been
modernizing
since y2k it's expensive
risky and it takes forever
and if you work with developers you know
it's difficult
for them to resist the temptation to
improve
things along the way this of course sets
off a chain reaction of yet more
software and business process changes
further prolonging the effort meanwhile
the technology around you is changing
all the time
the idea of having a clean slate a fresh
start
sounds great but unfortunately
experience shows
that it almost never works
what about emulating the mainframe
environment while you can't achieve
true cloud scale performance with a
single mainframe
pound for pound it's actually really
good hardware
most of the problems lie in the
ecosystem layer
and in the cost structure so by
emulating your mainframe
software to run on different hardware
you're really throwing away
probably the only good thing about the
system
and keeping all the stuff that's
actually holding you back
you incurred many of the same risks as
in other migration approaches
but realize few of the benefits
what about in-situ modernization we also
see
companies try to modernize in place they
conclude that their own software is the
primary problem and needs to be updated
at the same time they attempt to bring a
pseudo cloud
capabilities to the mainframe this
doesn't solve
any of the problems of cost or talent
scarcity
and it still involves a large manual
effort to
update existing software it's a very
expensive way
to prolong the inevitable
at google we have a different
perspective
we talk to our customers we feel their
pain
and they've been looking to their cloud
partners for a way to migrate these
mainframe workloads to the cloud
we've built a solution called g4
it combines google's considerable
engineering capabilities with decades of
mainframe modernization experience
we've developed this expertise in
technology internally
as well as through key acquisitions
what is g4 the g4 platform
is a set of tools developed and proven
over the last
25 years that transforms your legacy
mainframe applications
to run natively on google cloud by
converting legacy code to java based on
open standards
with g4 we've successfully taken
customers from
cobalt to containers in a matter of
weeks
what was previously too expensive too
risky
too difficult is now possible at
google scale and we believe that this is
a unique offering
not available elsewhere in the market
let's talk about g4 for a minute and go
over what it does and how it works
g4 consists of three major components
the analyzer the converter and the
dashboard
the g4 analyzer parses your mainframe
source code
to understand your business logic and
program dependencies and relationships
the g4 converter applies conversion
rules to your mainframe code
and transforms it into modern
cloud-native java
the converter supports dozens of
mainframe languages
such as cobol pl1 rpg
jcl assembly and many others and can
also help modernize
database business logic ims and vsam
the g4 dashboard provides performance
and complexity metrics
about your software that assists in the
testing and tuning
of the applications at a high level
our migration process follows the tried
and true methodology that we use
for migrating other mission critical
workloads to google cloud
the insights from the g4 analyzer drive
the discovery and assessment phases
which feed into the g4 converter which
modernizes legacy mainframe code
proper validation verification and
testing
ensure that the business logic operates
as expected
and reduces risk the g4
analyzer parses and decomposes your
sources
into clusters which informs the optimal
migration strategy
g4 then converts the mainframe sources
cluster by cluster
and produces target code in java that is
optimized to run
in the cloud this cluster-based strategy
allows the customer to migrate their
applications in waves
and parallelize the migration effort
using a migration factory approach
and i should note here the code produced
by the g4 converter
is free and clear no license no lock-in
no
nonsense let me summarize
some of the important benefits that
customers can realize
with g4 you can reduce costs and risks
while increasing agility and innovation
costs decrease when you escape the
capital intensive mainframe
refresh cycle eliminate mips charges
and end reliance on undifferentiated
maintenance toil just to keep the
mainframe running
business risk is reduced by ending
reliance on a closed ecosystem of
unsupported software and a chronic
talent shortage
g4 increases operational efficiency
agility
and innovation by extending the life of
mature software assets
running them on the cloud and leveraging
existing
investments in your software by gaining
access to modern cloud technologies
you can further optimize adapt and
evolve your software in ways that were
not
previously feasible
with some of these benefits in mind i'd
like to share with you the journey of
one of our mainframe modernization
customers
we're working with a large credit data
aggregation company
you can think of them as a credit bureau
who is anticipating a 5x
increase in customer queries due to
recent changes in legislation
most of their mission critical
applications are written in cobalt
and running on both a mainframe and
as400 style systems
they're also making use of other
mainframe technologies like
kicks jcl easy tree and db2
due to the forthcoming increase in
demand the customer is looking to
migrate to a modern
scalable platform and to modernize their
applications
to support future enhancements
they had thousands of as400 in mainframe
programs
and 12 months to make it happen
what kinds of workloads did we migrate
in mainframe land
there are two major categories of
workloads
online and batch and they have different
architectural requirements
online programs process requests and
responses in real time
and record those transactions in a
database as they happen
so if i want to transfer 100
into my bank account i want that to
happen now and that would be an
online transaction this is also known as
oltp or online transaction processing
batch programs process book data often
to aggregate records generated
throughout the day and perform analyses
as an example a batch process might
aggregate all
trades that occur in a given trading day
and determine a bank's risk exposure
batch programs are scheduled using jcl
job control language
how do we modernize jcl batch programs
due to the extensibility of g4
we can create custom conversion rules
in this case we modernized the customers
jcl to run in cloud composer
a managed workflow orchestration service
in google cloud
based on apache airflow these workflows
trigger batch processes running on
compute engine
container optimized vms inside a managed
instance group
these batch processes are java
executables running the open jdk
runtime environment for online workloads
we deploy the converted mainframe
applications
to compute engine inside a managed
instance group
because these workloads are intended to
be accessed by partners and customers
over the public internet
we deployed a load balancer to direct
traffic to the vms
and we migrated the existing db2
database
to db2 luw in compute engine
depending on your access requirements
you might instead deploy
a vpn or an interconnect to your data
center
for secure communication within your
corporate network
and depending on your transaction
processing requirements
we can deploy db2 luw directly to google
cloud
or we can re-platform your relational
database to postgres
and deploy our cloud sql managed service
okay we've covered a pretty wide range
of topics in this talk
from computing history to cloud
economics to mainframe deployment
architectures
so here are a few key points i'd like to
highlight before you go g4
is a true end-to-end mainframe migration
solution from google it enables our
customers to reduce
costs and risks while increasing agility
and innovation
proofs of concept are in high demand by
our customers due to the potential this
has
to transform their business and
importantly google is the only cloud
provider
with an integrated end-to-end mainframe
modernization solution
thank you for joining me today at google
cloud next on air
i look forward to working with you on
your mainframe modernization journey
you